kritischer jetzt aber genug politik für
heute lassen wir uns über die grünen
reden immer noch im umfragetief mit
ihrem spritzigen spitzen cem özdemir und
katrin göring eckardt zwei super realo
dürfen jetzt monatelange eher linkes
wahlprogramm verkaufen cooler move liebe
grüne die belohnung aktuell sieben bis
acht prozent in den umfragen und in
ihrer verzweiflung greifen die grünen
jetzt zum äußersten häuserkampf häuser
wahlkampf im grunde klingel streiche und
wieder voll im grünen wird würde die
politik oder verschrottet ich mit dir
aber nicht ziehen gerade die grünen
ziehen gerade bundesweit um die häuser
quasi als die zeugen jehovas und das ist
natürlich pure verzweiflung grüne ihr
hat die chance verpasst weil
irgendwelche frischen gesichter nach
vorne zu schieben was ich den weg zum
beispiel diese kleine sahneschnitte
frische inhalte sie erwartet ja schon
keiner mehr von euch was wollte den
beweisen mit dem ganzen klingel terror
und erkennt hand mit dieser wahl und sex
gefilmt hat viele leute haben sollten
ob die ganzen klassen geschlossen wow
die laufen treppen hoch die wenig ihr
könnt das ja gerne machen grüne macht
das ruhig aber ich sage ganz offen ich
bin entschieden gegen tierversuche nach
wie vor
hier jetzt nicht im heute-show fanshop
nervte sie auf ihre stadt ständig
irgendwelche öko spannenden hör auf zu
bringen
dann schickten sie jetzt ihr heim und
bestellen sie das abwehrsystem öko
intelligente kamera erkennt diesen
nervigen grünen linker und reagiert
sofort mit vier bände dem pfefferspray
aus der anti biologischem anbau und
treppenhaus eco expo es weiter der
blutige drohung
nie wieder grüne im haus
[Applaus]